only you might be really good at this
which is great I have very clear
memories of being red confused about
this clear memories of being confused
clear memories of things not being clear
so that's why I'm going to go back over
this and hopefully having it you know
introduced it last year
now I'll rub their paw sort of confusing
gonna be more like oh yeah I remember
this okay so do you member what the idea
was for dinner angle we said if you got
any two wave functions actually it's not
just two if like I keep saying this but
if you're unfortunate enough to do max
at university you will discover that you
can actually have an even a series of
different kinds of wave functions yeah I
don't all together and what you'll get
coming for example we took silent close
what you'll get is another wave function
so wave plus wave what he cool let's see
where all the spots yeah okay what do we
got here just right that's why miss
something yeah stop messing with me or
something anywhere let's protect bigger
than um you get another wave function
but the difference is right number one
it's got a different amplitude because
we're adding up two things or you're
taking the difference of two things
we've had the same effect and also
there's a shift happening right it
doesn't start at some nice happy spot
it's that sort of partway through the
middle and it ends partly through the
middle as well which you'd expect with
the periodic right so therefore how to
rank Li how can you say this well if you
take two wave functions sine and cos
okay we can we can restate this right
and this is more like an identity so
it's not equals here it's actually
equivalence which is like equality
equivalence what's the difference of
equality means these two things are the
same for certain cases okay so for
instance when you see this these two
things are the same when and only when
or if
early if X takes on a certain value name
a two and a half right however that's
very different to saying something like
I can rewrite this when we were doing
quadratics right I can rewrite that as
this okay general form and this is just
the form which shows us what the roots
are okay now these are always equal
whatever values of a and B and C and
alpha and beta are you come up with okay
so that's the difference data quality at
equivalence and this one that we took
now is equivalent any values of X you
can check email any value maybe it'll
work okay so what do we have on the
right-hand side we said these two wave
functions you put them together you get
a new one that's different in two ways
or two ways amplitude okay which is this
number at the front so we call that R
that's the new amplitude right and then
you can pick any function you like you
remember we started off with sine okay
and the other difference of poverty
amplitude was you can say in two ways
you can say shifts or a more techy way
of saying is its phase okay
so I've moved it left or right so that
phase is represented by on the auxilary
angle this is the auxilary angle of
auxilary angle okay now do you remember
the key to working out these kinds of
questions is working out with this two
things up number one what's the new
amplitude and what is the new face or
what is the UM
what is the auxilary angle okay
so seeing as this is review let's go
through this really really quickly how
do you actually come up with the way
what's the way that you we work out what
these two dollars are Jamilla
good coefficient you fought yeah that's
that's right or maybe coefficient
comparison so what you do is because you
guys are handy-dandy three unit students
you know how to expand this right hand
side so if you take the eye out the
front what are we going to end up with
here this is just sine a plus B right so
you've got sine X cos alpha plus cos x
sine alpha and you can see the
comparison two coefficients that were
interested in are this a is the
coefficient of sine X but so what's the
coefficient of sine X here it'll be R
cos alpha right so that's why we say a
is equal to R cos alpha okay and then
the other coefficient we're interested
in is the B which corresponds to again
the arc is multiplying everything but
sine alpha right so that's always a B
equals R sine alpha okay now do you
remember
there's an identity that we can take
advantage of which will let us get our
out of this equation without the angles
and how do we do that
you square both of these and then you
add them together you get a cos squared
plus cosine squared just one so skipping
a few steps because you're familiar with
this now right if we solve
simultaneously before our you get square
root of my favorite things in okay so I
tell you um yeah yeah yeah you can do it
then however later on there are dangers
in using ten but we'll get to them oh
it's probably safest to go with this
basic sort of format all right so let's
just quickly run through an example and
then let's have a look at the four
natural forms for example okay so
example sine X plus cos x Cleary right
it let's just take it in this form our
sine X plus alpha we'll look at the
other three in a second this is going to
be equal to Oh Simone
Plus alpha so how do we get each bit we
need to know what a and B are right
that's where everything else comes from
the a and the B are both 1 in this case
so I can write down our cars alpha is
equal 1 our side our farm is also equal
to 1 and so therefore if ours the square
root of a square plus Q square it's just
root 2 right I'm tracking with that mod
slowly I'm here for you ok so you can
take this through 2 and bring it up into
either of these equations so I might
take it into this first one okay if I
divide through by our I'm getting cos
alpha be equal to 1 or 2 okay so there's
your angle okay doing it in radians
right there's our there's alpha so
therefore the R sine X plus 1/2 I'm
interested in is simply root 2 sine X
plus pine for just coming back to the
example we did right at the beginning
that sort of checks out doesn't it
reduce it at one point for something
which looks about it looks about right
my scales a bit off but you get the idea
and also when you think about the shift
it is pilot for if I went pined for a
little more you can - it started off at
a nice neat spot rather than midway
through the curve ok